Hello guys, my name is Fez and I want to thank you guys for trusting me and I want to thank
you guys for purchasing this course.
Now this is an introduction video and I want to tell you guys what I will be teaching you
in this course.
So first of all we are going to learn about market structure, what is a breakup structure,
what is a change of character, what is imbalance or farewell gap, whatever you want to call it,
what is an autoblock, what is a reactionary autoblock, what is supply, what is demand.
And after that we are going to learn our main trading strategies.
So I have around 8 trading strategies and I will teach each and every strategy that
I use.
Now first of all we are going to learn Asian session liquidity strategy, after that it's
going to be New York session liquidity strategy, then autoflow trading strategy.
And on number 4 we have the 830am trading strategy, after that we are going to learn
about under over pattern trading strategy and then ABC trading strategy and then we have
the ABCD trading strategy and at last we have the reactionary block trading strategy.
Now you are not going to find any of these strategies on YouTube or on any other courses.
This is my own system that I have created through backtesting.
I will not teach you the basic SMC strategies and I am sure they do not work as good as
these strategies.
So once again I want to thank you guys for purchasing this course and I can guarantee
in the next 3-4 months you are going to make a lot of money and trust me if you put your
effort and hard work in this course you are going to become a really really good trader.
So thank you once again and I will see you in the next video.